Buenas tardes es un ambiente de
solemnidad pero al mismo tiempo de
respeto son más y más las personas que
quieren seguir uniéndose a esta fila que
ya está en el sadac Park que fue cerrada
porque alcanzó su máxima capacidad en
las horas de la noche del viernes por
fortuna haya sido reabierta esta fila y
el tiempo de espera ha bajado a 16 horas
pero el gobierno ha advertido que en
este fin de semana más Personas querrán
unirse Y seguramente podrá alcanzar esa
capacidad máxima entonces tendría la
fila que cerrarse y no podrán más
personas unirse ha habido momentos de
felicidad en medio del frío Pese a que
está haciendo sol porque el Rey Carlos
III y su hijo William El Heredero al
Trono acaban de ir a uno de los puntos
de la fila en el lado sur del Río
támesis en Londres para saludarles para
agradecerles hemos visto mucha
emotividad por parte del el público que
han agradecido el gesto pero sobre todo
para honrar la memoria de Isabel segunda
William por ejemplo les ha dicho a estas
personas que son muy valientes sobre
todo por hacer esas filas tan largas en
semejante frío entre tanto en las
últimas horas Fue capturado un hombre
que intentó lanzarse al ataúd de Isabel
segunda durante la cámara ardiente en el
West Mister Hall la policía actuó
rápidamente pero no se conocen mayores
detalles y Luisa precisamente nos
hablaba también ya de las acciones del
Rey Carlos III quien está empezando ya a
recibir algunos de los líderes que se
han desplazado a Londres para el funeral
de estado de quién se trata quién hemos
visto llegar ya a la capital
ya están los líderes los primeros
ministros del commonwealth la
mancomunidad de Naciones que integran 56
países desde Inglaterra territorios del
Caribe El Rey Carlos III tendrá una
audiencia hoy con los primeros ministros
de Canadá de Australia de Nueva Zelanda
de Jamaica y de otros pero también el
Rey Carlos ofrecerá una recepción este
domingo en la noche a los dignatarios
que asistirán a este país para el
funeral del lunes hay 2000 invitados
será el evento de seguridad y logístico
más grande en la historia británica ya
se ha movilizado miles y miles de
efectivos de la policía de diferentes
regiones del Reino Unido para unirse a
ese operativo va a estar el cielo aéreo
en los espacios aéreos de Londres
cerrados durante el funeral y miles y
miles de personas se esperan y tendrán
que pasar por controles de seguridad Así
que se ha advertido a las personas que
si quieren llegar a estas zonas tendrán
que hacerlo muy temprano en las primeras
horas de este lunes